l'entourage de julian assange peut
encore souffler un peu notamment grâce à
cette décision de la haute cour de
londres ce qui s'est passé au tribunal
aujourd'hui est précisément ce que nous
voulions qu'ils se produisent maintenant
la cour d'appel doit décider si elle
entendra l'appel mais ne vous méprenez
pas nous avons gagné aujourd'hui devant
le tribunal
mais n'oublions pas qu'à chaque fois que
l'on gagne temps que cette affaire n'est
pas abandonner tant que julian n'est pas
libérer julian continue de souffrir en
d'autres termes le fondateur de
wikileaks est autorisé à contester
devant la cour suprême britannique une
décision de justice autorisant son
extradition vers les etats-unis l'année
dernière une juge britannique vanessa
bas raiders avaient pourtant tranché en
sa faveur elle s'était opposée à
l'extradition de julian assange motif le
risque de suicide du fondateur de
wikileaks
mais les états unis avaient entre temps
selon la justice britannique fourni des
assurances sur le traitement réservé à
l'australien de 50 ans la décision de la
juge bas raiders avaient été annulés
pour le rédacteur en chef de wikileaks
les garanties des états unis ne sont pas
suffisantes
tous ceux qui ont examiné ces soi-disant
garantir les ont condamnés les a jugés
comme ne valons pas grand chose le
gouvernement américain a déjà donné de
telles garanties il ne les a pas
respectées
dans ces garanties il y a une clause qui
stipule peuvent changer d'avis à tout
moment donc ça ne vaut rien
[Musique]
pour rappel les etats-unis reprochent à
julian assange d'avoir diffusé plus de
700 mille documents classifiés sur les
activités militaires et diplomatiques
américaines notamment en irak et en
afghanistan
il est poursuivi pour espionnage et
risque la base 100 75 ans de prison en
attendant julian assange est incarcéré
au royaume uni non loin londres depuis
deux ans et demi